hi everyone I am Matt welcome the
editor-in-chief of Reason magazine which
some of you read and welcome here thank
you for coming through all of the
horrific heat outside we have a very
special night ahead of us we're gonna
have an hour-long conversation with the
great David Stockman author of the great
deformation the corruption of capitalism
in America he is a human sort of
myth-busting machine disrupting
narratives and making people call him
things like spittle flex pages before we
get too much into it round of applause
for Matthew before we get started a
couple of programming notes first of all
we're gonna do this for an hour the
first half hour or so will be me asking
questions the second half hour will be
the smart questions which will come from
all of you particularly those who have
expertise in the fields which are under
discussion and as a reminder of all of
that of course questions are welcome
speeches are a little bit less welcome
we will be taping this and are taping
this even right now as we speak on
recent TV which means that if you don't
want to be on TV don't do anything weird
and and don't ask a question and also
there are books this book here accepting
better without the coffee stains
available for free outside you can grab
one and if you're super nice to David
Stockman he might even sign it or write
exactly when he thinks the entire
financial system is going to collapse
and then who and then beyond that but
this whole night would not have been
made possible if it wasn't for the
extreme generosity of the Smith Family
Foundation Don Smith where are you okay
David Stockman first ran for Congress
and won a seat in 1976 at the age of 30
or so so yeah or so he is famously
Ronald Reagan's Boy Wonder
budget director from 1981 he quit in a
huff in 85 or so and went to Salomon
Brothers which I think that means you're
at the scene of a lot of crimes
throughout modern financial history also
with the Blackstone Group and after tarp
and the great financial freakout of 2008
started getting heavily into the news
cycle with very counterintuitive
criticisms of how Washington kind of
bipartisan bailout economics have ensued
and what that means for the future and
what that means for the hundred years or
so that led up to this moment
culminating in the great deformation
which is a rip-roaring and very
entertaining read before we delve into
the book a little bit since we have you
here and there's news in Wall Street Ben
Bernanke made a lot of headlines last
week talking about tapering off the bond
buyback program everybody's freaking out
can you just for the sake of this
audience here what's your take on that
where does that fit into your overall
kind of thesis about Federal Reserve
policy well if you want me to explain
what he's doing I don't have the
slightest idea but I'm not alone in that
because he doesn't either I do want to
say a couple of things before I try to
answer that question directly including
the fact that yes my career did involve
being present at the scene of many
crimes and one of
them occurred in 1976 when I was elected
to Congress at age 29 and I had two
other 29 year old hotshots who were
elected with me on the one side was Dan
Quayle and the other side was Al Gore so
you can see where the crime started
there
I do appreciate Matt before we get into
the Fed and all the issues that you had
some nice things to say about my book
it's been out two months now and so far
it's been denounced by the right and the
left and Republicans and Democrats and
Keynesian zand monitors and surprised by
this beginning and also Wall Street in K
Street and the military-industrial
complex as well as the neocons the
social cons and the just cons which is
about everybody else in Washington as I
think most of you know now I'm not
complaining about that the reaction has
been fair enough because the book does
call out crony capitalism for what it is
and I basically say that what we have
today is a perversion of free markets
and what we have today is a system that
is putting basic political democracy as
we have been led to understand it in
school very much at risk so I expected a
lot of brickbats a lot of negative
reactions but frankly I think some of
the critics went over the top and
particularly professor Paul Krugman who
as many of you know is the self anointed
and self-appointed authority on all
matters of economics in terms of what's
correct and not correct and I really
thought it was unfair that he went over
the top when he called my book the
ravings of a cranky old man even that
aroused
even my 85 year old mother who upon
reading his blog which had the
imprimatur of the New York Times
entitled actually cranky old man
immediately shot me back an email saying
doesn't he know you were actually a
cranky young man too
I've never got over but I think there
must be a lot of cranky people in
America and this is the recent bringing
all this up who are cranky about the way
things are going about the kind of
outrageously bad policy that we're
getting out of Washington and the Fed in
a lot of other places because the day he
put out his cranky old man blog my book
shot to the very top of the Amazon list
and there were only two things that two
diet books that stopped it and some
another thing called The Walking Dead
which I'm glad to believe is some kind
of novel Horror Story in any event I was
pleased that that happened and I say
this in a very humble way really not a
boastful way but as a result of that the
first week that it was out in early
April it's shot in week one to number
four on the New York Times bestseller
list and the reason that I'm not
boasting is that they're still having a
debate at the New York Times about
whether that would be number four on the
fiction or the nonfiction list and it
seems like there's a lot of Keynesian
economists who would like to dismiss the
whole thing is fiction
so getting to fiction we had fiction
last week when Bernanke said that he was
going to tan a taper and when you put
this in historic context which is really
what my book tries to do it's kind of a
hundred year revisionist history when he
says that he was tapering or might think
about soon or sometime down the road
taper the 85 billion a month of
purchases by the Fed in the debt markets
forty billion of which was government I
mean GSEs of mortgage-backed securities
government guaranteed the rest of being
Treasury paper this would have caused
Carter glass the author of the Fed in
1913 exactly a hundred years ago today
to be rolling in his grave
and I think it's kind of
is symptomatic it triggers the whole
discussion about where we are why we
have crony capitalism why the free
market is failing why government is out
of control why our financial system is
heading for some kind of crack up not
too far down the road because if you
compare what Bernanke was saying last
week to the model to the design that
Carter glass and many of you know him
from glass-steagall but the design that
he had in mind when he was chairman of
the Banking Committee and adopted the
Fed legislation in 1913 it's really
mind-boggling to consider the facts
number one the Fed as he designed it and
he imparted last was I think one of the
great financial statesmen of the 20th
century the the Fed could not buy
government bonds it was not even allowed
to be near buying any kind of government
paper whether it was bills notes or
bonds that's the first thing the second
thing is that there weren't any
government bonds to buy anyway in 1913
the total debt in the United States was
1 billion dollars which amounted to $12
per capita which even in today's badly
depreciated currency is only 400
compared to the 55,000 per capita in
today's dollars that we have and more
interestingly the government debt
outstanding this minor 1.2 billion 4%
are actually 3 percent of GDP had not
changed in nominal terms since the
Battle of Gettysburg amazingly between
1863 and 1913 50 years the nominal debt
and the United States did not go up we
had small government we had sound money
and also we had an economy that grew
pretty well notwithstanding what the
Keynesian tell you today about the
dystopia that allegedly existed in the
late 19th century when we were having
crashed and busts in banking panics and
so forth according to professor Krugman
all the time actually according to
Christina Rome
who I guess is not some kind of you know
nutjob from the right like like I'm
alleged to be but she was the go-to
student of the 19th century her studies
show that between 1870 or 1869 and 1913
real GDP grew at a compound rate of 3.7
percent a year for 40 years running in
other words it was the strongest period
of sustained economic growth of general
prosperity of rising living standards in
modern history we've never replicated
anything like that sense except for
periods of war and frankly wars are not
a good way to meet your Keynesian
targets well I go into this little
historical digression because if you
look at what Carter glass had in mind in
a world where there was no government
debt in the world where there were
budget surpluses not deficits in which
there was no bond market and which he as
the author
hated Wall Street and didn't want to
have the Fed to have anything to do with
it that's why we have 12 Federal Reserve
region banks in San Francisco Boston
Dallas and so forth the idea was that
the Fed would only be a bankers bank
that would run a discount window in 12
locations when real commercial bankers
bought brought good commercial paper
such as inventory paper or receivables
to the Fed for cash on a discounted
basis at a penalty rate of interest
above the free market rate that was the
Carter glass design there was no open
market operation there was no bond
buying not 85 billion not 40 billion not
anything
there was no targeting of the of any
economic variables they weren't going to
target obviously GDP because frankly
they couldn't even measure at that they
weren't going to target unemployment or
inflation or housing starts or
industrial production or retail sales or
any of the rest of it even m1 they were
going to tar
I'm not going to target because they
didn't know how to measure m1 but my
point is it was a passive institution to
provide liquidity to a banking system
that served an industrial and business
economy that would grow based on the
interaction of producers and consumers
and investors and speculators and the
whole population of a free society and a
free economy the government didn't care
what the GDP growth rate or the
unemployment rate was or anything else
the Fed targeted nothing because the job
of a discount window based central bank
was simply to provide liquidity to a
banking system that responded to the ebb
and flow of Commerce now I think it's
important to revive what the original
design was to compare it to Bernanke
last week trying to decide through you
know mumbo jumbo words and word clouds
whether he was tapering or not tapering
in a market that is totally dominated by
a central bank that rigs everything
every price in the financial markets
whether it's a bill price or a no price
or a bond price or a spread for MBS
against the Treasury or whether it's a
risk asset price like the russell 2000
and many others all are basically
managed medicated and rigged by an
overwhelming dominant central bank today
that I call a national monetary planning
system the opposite of a free economy
and I bring all this together here
because it says in a hundred years
we've drifted to something that worked
to something that today is essentially
economic totalitarianism if you really
want to boil it down to a phrase now the
reason I've said this is that a lot of
things happened along the way over a
hundred years to get us from Carter
glasses
kurz Bank passive discount window - this
kind of monetary Politburo of 12 people
that run the financial system of the
United States and the world today out of
the Eccles building but that takes is
730 pages to get through all the steps
along the way and hopefully that's
really what I was addressing in the book
and that tonight we can get into some of
the crucial you know turning points
inflection points that happen that
goddess from Carter glass you know
bothering the Federal Reserve in 1913
the Bernanke omitting word clouds last
week about tapering or not tapering in a
central bank dominated economy well
let's talk about the inflection point
that you begin the book with which is
basically the fall of 2000 right and 8
you make the provocative claim in fact
I've kind of be curious to see how many
people in this audience agree with a
claim that in September of 2008 fall of
2008 there was no risk of financial
contagion it's complete fiction
according to David Stockman how do you
believe that that way how many don't
believe that by the way all right and
how many people work here in the
financial end of like and how many are
in both categories so talk about this
you go point by point AIG insurance
company wasn't as a wasn't at a risk of
contagion debunked this myth for these
skeptics okay I think the first point is
I call it the blackberry panic of 208
because I believed it happened in a few
days around about the time of the Lehman
failure when policy was dominated by a
bunch of people on the third floor of
the Treasury Building in Washington that
I call the occupiers I mean actually the
bailouts and tarp and all the bad things
that came out of that particular moment
in time just a few days was due to the
occupiers but the occupiers were goldman
sachs that's the you know that's the
different slant on it but essentially
hank paul
you know was looking at his blackberry
and he could see the price of the S&P
dropping by the hour you can see the
price of golden Sachs which had peaked I
think way up at 350 a few years after
the IPO cutting under a hundred heading
toward 65 and bottoming for a couple
panic moments there at about 48 I think
it was and it was looking at those
blinking number green of red numbers on
his blackberry that induced him into a
totally frenzied state of mind that
quickly spread to the rest of the
government because the rest of the
government was clueless and they took
his word for it because he's a Wall
Street man I mean obviously George Bush
was clueless the Congress was totally
buffaloed we know what happened when
they were brought up to the hill and he
got down on his knees and begged Nancy
Pelosi that tells you that the whole
system was clueless at that point in
time but what I'm saying is if you look
at it carefully you had a unique
historical interception and I'm pretty
much a determinist I think big forces
drive history but I think in the context
of big forces you had two personalities
that created a massive panic based on
either a self-interested biased
perception or vast misunderstanding the
other personality was Bernanke he claims
to be a scholar of the Great Depression
I disputed heatedly
I think he is a math modeler who
unfortunately Xerox Milton Friedman's
erroneous you know view of what the Fed
did in 1930 31 and 32 and on the basis
of that alleged Authority which was
taken for granted not really debated
examined or understood in Washington he
suddenly said Great Depression 2.0 is
around the corner we're facing a monster
all the rules get thrown out we're going
to have to
do massive sort of incomprehensible
things in terms of all of the rules
about fiscal rectitude and market
responsibility for mistakes and bad
trades and so forth and they believed
him and the two of them put Washington
into a pan they tried to pass you know I
mean I I was in the fiscal process and I
could just tell you the feel of a seven
hundred billion dollar blank cheque in a
system that normally debates and you
know massages stuff for months and
months and years and years in itself was
kind of a panic inducing moment and so
when suddenly this alleged scholar of
the Great Depression and this other guy
who's watching his Blackberry and he's a
attention span of a few hours at best
declare that we're heading for a massive
economic meltdown of historic
proportions it then spread around the
system and out of that people began to
believe all kinds of things based on
casual ad-hoc self-serving arguments
that they made up by the seat of their
pants that weren't true and in my book
for about seventy pages where they go
through it I won't go into all of them
now but let me mention for quickly one
after Lehman failed the next day they
reverse course and said they had to bail
out AIG the idea that AIG was some kind
of economic contagion that was going to
spread globally simply because it was so
big and it's balance sheet was eight
hundred billion is one of the greatest
urban legends of modern times because
the problem at AIG was the holding
company only it was actually run out of
London as many of you know it was the
agency that had sold all of the CDs
credit default swaps to the ten or
twenty largest banks in the world based
on the balance sheet of consolidated
Taichi which had plenty of capital
plenty of equity except the problem for
all the smart guys at sock Jen and
Citibank and Morgan's JP Morgan and the
rest of them who bought the CD s from
the holding company was they never asked
about the liquidity question that is
could all of the capital in the equity
that was buried in dozens of AIG
insurance companies the PMF you know
property and casualty operations
retirement annuity operations life
insurance companies and so forth there
were dozens of them that added up to
this consolidated balance sheet could
the holding company at will extract
capital in unlimited amounts or cash in
unlimited amounts so that it would then
sell this stuff into the market create a
downward contagion in order to meet the
margin calls that it was getting on the
credit default swaps as the you know
subprime market on wound drastically in
mid-september now the truth of the
matter is that all of those insurance
companies had dividend stoppers they
were regulated by state insurance
Commission's for better or worse it was
their the holding company could not
extract any meaningful cash or capital
from any of these dozens of subsidiaries
that had good good assets and so
therefore there was never going to be
any contagion selling there was never
going to be any meltdown because the
insurance commissioners would have
seized the subsidiaries
if AIG had gone into bankruptcy as the
other alternative so essentially what
you had then was no liquidity in the
holding company in about 20 big banks in
the world that had foolishly bought
credit default insurance so they could
own subprime mortgage-backed securities
book the high-yield and not have to book
any profit or any
capital as you know because if you had
CD s triple a CD s from AIG under the
rules of Basel rules you didn't need to
post any capital so they didn't have to
put up any capital they were collecting
the spread they were paying almost
nothing for the insurance
this was a small catastrophe that would
have caused the phony biggest banks of
the world
New York London and Paris to lose about
60 billion I've already calculated it
through it's not my numbers that came
from the Crisis Inquiry Commission of
Congress but the 60 billion amounts to
one half of 1% of the combined balance
sheet of these huge banks that had 20
trillion of footings between them in
other words it would have caused a few
quarters worth of losses it would have
caused some stock options and bonuses
not to be awarded in 208 it wouldn't
have caused any of these great
institutions Barclays or BNP Paribas or
stock gen or Citibank to go down because
in Europe the socialist governments
would have backed them up anyway and in
the United States they could have put it
if they had to into resolution by the
FDIC now the reason I go through this is
that it was it was the image of AIG that
until then and some of you are in the
financial markets others aren't but if
you were in the financial world from the
90s and through the up through the great
crisis of 208 AIG had a powerful in
motive symbolic mean AIG was the gold
standard of Finance and that's how
people had grown up that's what they
thought AIG was the miracle place that
had an 800 billion dollar balance sheet
and when suddenly AIG and one day was
going to go down the tubes and take the
world with it and needed a hundred and
eighty billion dollars of totally
inconceivable bailout you know capital
and cash from the government
that's what started everybody down it
opened a new chapter it put everybody in
a frame of mind that there was some you
know comment from outer space that had
suddenly arrived him the financial
markets with some deadly contagions that
were going to take everything down so it
was the AIG mistake that happened in a
couple of days because you know why
Bernanke was a B excuse me
Halsey was running around with his hair
on fire that part of it which he still
had served by a bunch of young guys who
had been M&A bankers at goldman sachs
who knew nothing about insurance who had
no facts about the true situation of AIG
and they simply railroaded and panicked
everyone into this one two day you know
a massive move on AIG well once you did
that well then pretty soon everything
else starts to line up and you get panic
calls from Jeff I melt a head of GE
saying oh gee you know my commercial
paper rates gone from two to six percent
I don't like that next thing you know
while they were at it they bailed out
they nationalized the commercial paper
market didn't need to be done there was
this whole thing about the money market
funds were going down the drain I'll
shorten this up by saying I go through
it there were three point eight trillion
of money market funds outstanding half
of them were basically called prime
funds which means mostly bank government
paper it was good they had a little
commercial paper and when Lehman went
down some of the prime funds got hit the
other half one point eight trillion was
government only funds and there was
never one dollar of you know withdrawal
of panic run on the one point eight
trillion now the truth of the matter is
not notwithstanding what Bernanke kept
telling congressional committees and
Paulson and all the rest of them if you
look at the data which comes from the
Investment Institute so it's not yeah
numbers I'm making up out of that whole
three point eight trillion 400 billion
moved through the push of a button by
most investors who had their accounts at
Big Foot
you know fund companies that did both
kinds they move four hundred billion
roughly from the prime funds to the
government only funds that's what
happened I mean it didn't go into
mattresses it didn't go down to black
hole there wasn't any kind of huge run
on the you know money market funds going
on and of the entire amount less than
sixty billion actually left the money
market fund families it simply moved
from column a to column B the sixty
billion that actually left is a couple
percent it wasn't the end of the world
and most of it went into bank paper
anyway so you could go through all the
rest of it should we have bailed out
goldman sachs of course not if golden
sachs had met its maker in Chapter
eleven there would have been eleven sons
of goldman that would have been
reconstituted out of it and that would
be run by people today who are far more
prudent because they would have you know
had to suffer the consequences of losing
the value of their stock there wasn't
any retail bank run going on in america
other than Washington Mutual which was
basically a Wall Street creation anyway
but if you look at retail banks in
America and I go through this in the
book twelve trillion of assets the the
amount of toxic assets in retail Main
Street banking not Wall Street hedge
funds that were otherwise known as
investment banks there was not any risk
of the whole thing coming on wound of
lines at the teller windows in all the
rest finally there was no Great
Depression 2.0 anywhere in sight and I
have quite an analysis in the book to
show how Bernanke had it upside down
the Great Depression in 1930 happened
because we were a huge exporter and
creditor to the world and when the world
economy collapsed our export economy
laughs and it spread to the rest of the
system in 208 we were a massive importer
we were a huge debtor to the world
obviously we know all that and so when
the world economy went down as a result
of the panic in September the
Hoovervilles were in the interior of
China they weren't in Pittsburgh and
they weren't in Detroit in Chicago and
st. Louis and other places where it
happened in 1930 well you can go through
a lot of analysis of the structure in
the economy we now have a safety net we
had unemployment insurance we had food
stamps we had many things that cushion
the downward flow of spending as a
result of a minor amount of income
dislocation that occurred but it isn't
remotely comparable or describable as
Great Depression 2.0 so to sum it up if
a IG isn't a contagion let's go to wreck
the planet if the money market funds
we're not going into some giant meltdown
if you go through the commercial paper
market whatever they were saying about
ATMs going dark and so forth is not
remotely true if GE a triple-a credit
could not fund a few billion of
commercial paper if you considered the
fact that there was no bank runs that
were going to happen or Great Depression
that was going to happen then what
happened in September to October 208 was
a drastic horrendous historical mistake
it was a Rubicon because it was done by
a Republican White House and it was done
by a Republican Congress in
administration and so if they're going
to throw out all the rules of free
markets if they're going to throw fiscal
rectitude to the winds passing the seven
hundred billion dollar tarp if they're
going to basically say that markets
don't work and therefore anything that's
big and interactive interconnected can't
be allowed to fail and that is financial
institutions when it makes mistakes
if you're going to predicate all of that
which is what the Bush White House did
and the Paulson in
and I really saves a coup d'etat Paulson
was running the government it was a coup
d'etat by Paulson and the Goldman people
right around the 3rd floor when all of
that happens you can't go back to Kansas
anymore it's gone free markets are gone
fiscal management is gone any kind of
even pragmatic notion of central bank
prudence is gone after Bernanke
increased the balance sheet of the Fed
and this is a startling factor than I'll
wind up with this
Bernanke increased the balance sheet of
the Fed between Lehman September 15 and
October 27 that's roughly seven weeks by
nine hundred billion dollars in seven
weeks which means he was expanding the
balance sheet at seven hundred million
dollars an hour each and every hour
during that interval and the reason I
bring it up is because the first 900
billion of the balance sheet of the Fed
had taken 94 years to produce in other
words starting with powdered glass and
going through good times and bad times
and good chairman
you know like blue McChesney Martin and
awful ones like Arthur burns through the
entire first 94 years of the feds
history it that's how long it took to
get 900 billion a balance sheet Bernanke
replicated it in seven weeks of panic
and then he tripled it in about 15 weeks
through the end of December that got it
to 2.3 trillion and now you know where
it is today three point four trillion
and even if they start to taper if they
can figure out what they're doing we're
going to end up in the four to five
trillion dollar range so this is a
central bank that is you know a rogue
institution run by hopeless Keynesian
academic zealots who don't even
understand that interest rates are the
price of money and they're not smart
enough those 12
geniuses on the Fed to figure out the
entire capital market of the world
and how everything that moves back and
forth by the nanosecond ought to be
priced but that's what they're doing
today it is a mission meant to blow up
explode create a massive dislocation and
failure and it's only a matter of time
and the good news is that Bernanke is
going back to Princeton in a few months
the bad news is that Yellen is worse so
if any of you have any hope don't
because it's not Meriden on September
24th 2008 of the day I'll always
remember because I think it was the only
time I was in the green room of the
Rachel Maddow Show John McCain I was
watching the George W Bush go on
national television at this great
formulation I really encourage everyone
to go and read that speech by the way of
all the stuff that he warned that would
happen to America if we didn't pass tarp
right away because he ticked off a list
you know a lot of regional banks are
gonna go under unemployment mico and
north of nine percent allowed everything
that he warned that would happen if we
didn't pass tarp it happened after we
passed her but he had this great
formulation of normally I'm a great
believer in free markets but I presume
it's your contention that normally he
wasn't a great believer in free markets
and can you talk about how Republican
conservative economics departed from a
better place and particularly what you
observed at the scene of one of those
crimes in the early 1980s what were some
of the crucial mistakes made that led to
a mindset that was so ready to accept
this different type of solution in 2008
okay that's a great question and just to
clarify the quote signs of money quote
Bush actually said I am abandoning the
rules of the free market if in order to
save the free market good for him
but it had been happening for a long
time incrementally during my period in
the White House I learned a few things
about how much Republicans really
believed in free markets in one of them
that's highlighted in the book and I
think it's important is that I basically
tried to kill Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
in the cradle in 1981 when they were
just getting going of course they had
been around you know Fannie Mae was
created during the Great Depression 38
by the New Deal but they had kind of
bounced along a moderate-sized with a
moderate role in the housing market
through 1980 and my idea was that they
were essentially using the credit of the
United States in order to guarantee
paper that's all they did there's
nothing behind the facade of those
buildings except you know a printing
press that would stamp guarantee and
they were not charging the market the
value of using the credit of the United
States so I came up with a simple thing
that would have killed him off a
guarantee fee that would make the yield
on the paper that they were guaranteed
guaranteed rise to a market clearing
level now that would have killed them
long ago before they became huge in the
early 90s and then monstrous by the late
90s and then the kind of world
destroyers that they became by 2:07 but
that effort was killed by the
Republicans in the House on the House
Banking Committee because they said that
housing is too important to be left to
the free market and therefore we need to
have a continued role for Fannie and
Freddie you know bolstering home
ownership and making credit available on
on economic terms to people who deserve
it now it's interesting to say that
because so 1981 was an opportunity
missed
among many along the way
I bring it up because today with a lot
of fanfare a Republican senator corker
who's thought to be moderately
conservative introduces the corker
Warner bill to reform the GSEs Fannie
Mae and Freddie Mac and guess what
they're doing they're going to take them
out of existence and create a new
program to insure mortgage-backed
securities that are issued by the
private sector so we learn nothing the
Republican Party you know never seems to
understand what the free market is we
had a near-death experience with a total
collapse of the housing market with
massive distortions as we all know going
on that we're altima you know fueled and
and supported by Freddie and Fannie with
six trillion dollar balance sheets they
ultimately needed to be nationalized and
yet here we are after all of that you
know near-death experience and the
leading Republican says I'm going to
re-create them with a new name but it's
still the same old game now why in the
world do we need to I can't really house
lead in the free market why do we need
to have interest rates that are
four-and-a-half percent when maybe they
would be six and a half percent on
30-year mortgages in the free market why
do we need to have 65 percent
homeownership rate not 69 percent that
we had at the peak or 55 percent which
they have in Germany and you could go on
and on now the point is if the
Republicans who are looking for an issue
because you know they're lost out there
somewhere you know if they're looking
for an issue and they're trying to you
know capitalize on the legitimate fear
that the American public had as a result
of the great financial crisis
experienced they can't even come up with
an honest program to shut down the GSE
monsters that have no place no need for
existence they can't even come up with
that what else happened along the way so
many of them you know what
about the farm programs we couldn't get
rid of them still can now everybody says
well isn't it nice they defeated the
farm bill yesterday but the the point is
or two days ago the farm bill was
defeated by Liberal Democrats who didn't
want to reform by a tiny one or two
percent the food stamp program the rest
of it was passed by Republicans who
thought it would be just great to have
in this world that we're living in today
massively subsidized crop insurance so
that farmers could go out and you know
produce wheat let's say on arid lands
when there seems to be you know weather
patterns that interfere with the
profitability of that so my point is you
could go up and down the spectrum and
you can't see a lot of evidence of sound
free-market policy coming from
Republicans where it could make a
difference and then ultimately of course
the problem is the Fed and it's rather
interesting if you look at what Boehner
said a couple days ago he said the Fed
is deflating the money too much or
something in other words it was
incomprehensible I mean it was you know
it was a babble okay and so if you have
a monstrous threat to sound money in
free markets like the central bank today
run by a guy who was put on the central
bank to run it by Karl Rove then maybe
you can put a you know the connected
dots and realize that there is no hope
in the Republican Party I have one
little section in my book but I like to
bring it up because Karl Rove I think is
the essence of everything that is wrong
with what used to be the conservative
party the Republican Party in the United
States and here in the early first Bush
term he had the wisdom to get Paul
O'Neill fired because O'Neill said
you're gonna have another war you ought
to pay for it out of taxes which I
firmly believe the way you stop the war
fair state is to have people pay taxes
and then they'll find out whether they
want to put pants on the natives you
know in Iraq and other places around the
world and he said I'm gonna fire O'Neal
for the temerity to say that you know we
have to raise taxes to finance the war
and I'm going to prove I'm going to
appoint Bernanke to the Fed first and
then as chairman of the Council of
Economic Advisers to the president
second and 205 and then third as a
reward for that making chairman of the
Fed when anybody could have read the
man's written lifetime work and see that
he was a total Keynesian status money
printing demand-side you know economists
that hat should have not even been given
the time of day
by a Republican White House but this has
all happened in our time you know this
isn't history this isn't theory this is
reality this is what Republicans do when
they're in power and so therefore if
Republicans do this then where do we get
out of this box we certainly aren't
going to look to the Democrats for
salvation so my aunt my bottom line is
until the party system goes through a
massive realignment and the Republican
Party breaks up and the warmongers and
the neocons and the social cons and the
people who want to run your private life
go off in one direction and people who
have a sense of fiscal integrity and
what real free market economics is about
go off in another direction there isn't
really a lot of hope of getting out of
this tangle that we're in today that's
Jerry
so where is our delicious inflation
we've been promised inflation by a lot
of critics trenchant critics of the
Federal Reserve and money printing and
Ben Bernanke over the years where where
is it we have massive inflation and what
the but the inflation that is massive
today is in financial asset prices not
in the cost of labor or in the Consumer
Price Index and what the historic sound
money people told you was that inflation
can be in goods and services or it can
be in financial assets but in either way
it's a bad thing that the great
inflation of financial assets that we
had in the 1920s eventually led to the
the collapse in 1929 and probably one of
the most astute diagnosis of that
financial asset inflation in the 20s
because there was no CPI change from
1928 well 1919 1920 9 the guy who looked
diagnosed that brilliantly was none
other than Alan Greenspan in 1966 who
wrote a very penetrating and I think
brilliant analysis of the issue of
inflation and that when you basically
cause financial assets through money
printing and manipulation of financial
markets and the puts that developed and
so forth to soar in value you're
creating the same kind of distortions in
a roundabout way or one step removed
that happen with goods inflation now as
long as we have a central bank system
that's worldwide I call it a convoy of
monetary Roach Motels that's what the
central banks are because they all buy
by you know the bond the bond comes in
it never goes out much of the sovereign
debt of the world today is in the
central banks they're all inflating
their systems and
result of that in the short run it's
bringing massive capacity into the world
economy by that I mean massive expansion
of mining capacity for copper or
aluminum or iron ore or nickel or any of
the rest of it massive expansion of
capacity for factory production by
draining the rice paddies and bringing
the peasants into the world economy so
the effect of central bank inflation is
to create a world boom that causes
capacity to expand rapidly due to
malinvestment over investment miss
investment all of that capacity both the
China price on labor and the massive
capacity to produce manufactured and you
know industrial of supplies keeps the
CPI down and it causes obviously the mat
the excess liquidity that's being
created to flow into financial assets so
that's why we get cereal bubbles you
know from dot-com to the housing bubble
to the credit bubble and now we're back
to the same thing you know today the
stock market actually closed the S&P 500
only about a point and a half a percent
and a half above where it was in October
9 207 and when it closed at that peak in
October 2 o 7 before the last collapse
of a bubble it was only slightly higher
than where it had been in march 2000 so
i think the pattern is that the modern
central banking what I call it fiat
central banking creates financial asset
inflation periodic bubbles that finally
reach an unsustainable level they
collapse on their own weight as soon as
confidence is you know disrupted for one
unexpected reason or another some kind
of black swan or unexpected event
like let's say Lehman and then they
collapse and they create all kind of
carnage obviously in their wait so the
inflation is here it's right in front of
your eyes it's all over the world
it's massively overvalued real estate
commodities financial assets of every
type the Fed resolutely ignores and
denies that and as a result they have a
policy which is extremely dangerous in
my view which says as long as we don't
get CPI inflation which by definition
you can't get when you're inflating a
global industrial economy and you're
still one you know peasant left in the
rice paddies if we can print money as
much as we want we can expand our
balance sheet with unlimited scope as
long as we don't get CPI inflation and
meanwhile we get bubble after bubble
every kind of distortion known to man
huge trading windfalls massive
rent-seeking in all of these
hyperactivated you know gambling markets
all of this one is bad for the real
economy and for real prosperity and real
living standards but second it gives
capitalism a bad name sooner or later
the people are going to get out their
pitchforks they're going to get out
their torches and they're going to come
after the one percent because the one
percent today our you know reaping these
huge windfalls whether it's on junk
bonds or real estate or some gut you
know godforsaken Fannie Mae preferreds
that they bought for one cent on the
dollar they're making these massive
windfalls due to central bank policy not
due to economic value creation and it's
only a matter of time before the people
get a little tired about this and we get
some real populism
and you know then if you think you know
we have problems with the way we're
running our fiscal accounts are running
you know our market process we're only
in the warm-up phase I want to make sure
that we have enough time for our
audience questions how we doing on time
here the wash lightning around you in
your opening include a list of villains
from a list of heroes villains include
Milton Friedman heroes include Bill
Clinton thirty Seconds it would take me
more than 30 seconds you know the thirty
second answer is Clinton balance the
budget I really have concluded after a
lifetime in this that there is a
fundamental issue of between starve the
beast or pay your bills that's a
fundamental question and I've come to
the conclusion that starve the beast is
a terrible thing because it gives people
that gives the people big government
without the yoke and burden of taxes to
pay for it and as a result of that the
politicians just build up the debt on
the future and the people don't feel the
pain today under the rule of pay your
bills which is what the old Republican
orthodoxy was and what Eisenhower that's
why he's a hero by the way in my book
actually implemented in the 50s by
paying your bills the people feel the
pain of the size of government that the
politicians are creating and it's only
when they feel the pain and not just the
2% of the 1% or something you're going
to hit you know with a surtax but the
whole middle class of productive economy
when they feel the pain then there is a
fair fight in the political arena
between the cost and the benefits the
trade-offs and how you pay for something
as opposed to what you're getting so
that's why I provocatively picked Bill
Clinton because I don't think on
economic policy he was all that
brilliant or virtuous but he did resist
the left he did say
as the surplus was coming in from
Greenspan's bubble of the 90s that we're
going to use this to balance the budget
and actually run some minor surpluses
and I give him credit for that
because it established the rule of pay
your bills and that's why in my book I
call for a balanced budget amendment to
the Constitution because you know
without it we're just going to bury the
future in one way or another you also
call for a wealth tax and in general as
you said before to pay as we go if we
taxed ourselves the level that we spent
would we not be in Ben Bernanke's Great
Depression 2.0 if we taxed ourselves at
the level we spent after a period of an
adjustment we would have less growth we
would have less efficiency we would have
less incentives we would have less
entrepreneurial energy we would have
many less lesser things we would have
many bad things and then the people
might begin to see that that's the cost
of government and if you want to have
this massive all-encompassing welfare
state then you're going to have a fairly
you know frugal existence ascetic
existence but I think that's what you
need to do and the Republicans have made
the mistake of saying we know how to
grow the economy through the
instrumentalities of the state but they
choose to use the tax code to stimulate
this and boost that and encourage the
other thing and they're playing the
Keynesian game from the tax side and I
think that's not the right way to go if
you want to have big government and pay
the full taxes and have a no growth
economy then the people can decide to do
that if you rather the libertarian view
of the world is more attractive and we
can get more economic growth than do
that or something in between on that
note I think we will wrap it up a
reminder took
this book in better form is out there
it's for you thanks again